Charlie bird was was a dream that took a
few years to come to fruition I really
just wanted to cook real food well and
one of the things that that we realized
right away was that our most valuable
asset as people and finding that was the
biggest problem for us in New York the
line cooks or the dishwasher really have
the advantage that they can go and
cherry-pick the places that they want to
because there's so many restaurants out
there and when we open the restaurant we
had to figure out how to work four
stations and there were only two cooks
so we had one dishwasher who would show
up some days and wouldn't show up other
days and suddenly there was cook didn't
show up and we found ourselves
scrambling so our says the general
manager Mike was running downstairs in
washing dishes every 15 minutes and he
wasn't there I was over there washing
dishes and that becomes you know real
challenge to be able to run a restaurant
kitchen without employees we realized we
had to look at multiple places to to
find great team members we need to look
at other restaurants and talk with other
chefs it took us a while to really build
that core that family our pasta is made
by my mother-in-law Rosa who is a 72
year old to Italian woman from campania
just outside of Napoli we should took
pity on us because we were making pastas
at three or four o'clock good morning so
just weren't enough hours in the day to
have food ready to go for the you know
onslaught of people that were showing up
at our door
this was something that really meant a
lot to us but then to the team members
that's all wow this is not just a job
this is a family that we're working with
and that made all the difference in the
passion that came out of the food and it
really played forward to the guests at
that point and people could taste it in
the food it's become an amazing success
story for us almost overnight we're back